un bateau avec deux voiles
au centre de bateau
très joli ça
pas mal
après il y a des chèvres trop drôles
pas des chèvres
là tu comprends c'est ton zoom en
approchant c'est ça que tu fais pour
l'instant non moi j'aime bien laisser
grossir pour qu'elle
aussi c'est non c'est rien
les chèvres il y a des chèvres
de laisser comme ça parce que tu vas
on dirait une montgolfière c'est joli ça
merde attends attends c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave
tu vois je peux pas m'arrêter
il change de sens comme ça
le mec il voit le truc il se dit on va
se casser la gueule
attention
il y en a un autre devant
le détail dans la bâche cette voile fait
de trucs
ah mais ah ouais comme ça
doucement
pardon il est grand il est long
il est où le bateau
tu l'effaces en est d'accord
pas à droite à gauche
sur la gauche OK
super en vertical c'est super on fait un
dodo
pas trop mignonne
du premier tu vois c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave
c'est du
sport doucement doucement et voilà j'ai
de rester un peu comme ça voilà c'est
super joli c'est super c'est top
allez
pas
à la poêle là tu peux dire
bouge pas
on y retourne
c'est que
soit un peu en biais sur un peu plus son
image tu vois comme ça voilà
OK
nos enfants vont voir assez de bateau
j'ai l'impression
en fait une verticale s'il te plaît en
France
il est bien ce plan ou pas j'avais
beaucoup de mal le voir
ce plan
voilà elle en prend plein la gueule donc
pour la
avec la souris devant le petit garçon
qui sourit avec la peinture c'est
magnifique
c'est vachement beau voilà
va
tout à l'heure tu peux couper ça
encore plus beau
super image
superbe 2 secondes encore
après un gros plan les enfants devant là
si j'arrive
par derrière
ok merci beaucoup
je sais pas
très joli
la marque et récupérer
tout le bateau en entier le devant en
bateau
je fais un peu de toi là j'avais
pas joli il était bien
d'avoir ce que tu veux
du coup tout le temps merde
s'il te plaît
ça va être bon pour tirer
la voile
bon je trouve ça les enfants
s'il te plaît
voilà voilà voilà voilà